does it my dear I don't know honey
thanks I want to get back to like what
made Johnny fall in love in the first
place I mean I would like one motorcycle
like a date in Riverdale but something's
with nothing going wrong it's good
though it's good your language you're
gonna become TBH I don't even know
what's going on there's some
unconditional love going on there yet
hmm she's putting underdosing I cannot
believe that Riverdale has never had a
Halloween episode before but it's
finally happening you guys look
absolutely incredible okay when you
found out that you were gonna be playing
poison ivy Harley Quinn initial
reactions I mean obviously excitement
the excitement also very perfect for our
characters I feel like and like I didn't
know how far we were gonna go with these
outfits I wasn't sure what customers was
gonna do when they never disappoint I
mean like they really went all out on
these boys so I haven't seen this
version of Harley Quinn before cos from
the original Harley Quinn costume but I
like I really like it
how does Cheryl and Tony do Halloween
and how does madellaine and Vanessa do
Halloween you know I'm actually
surprised because I didn't think Cheryl
intone you I do Halloween the way
they're doing it but I'm not gonna spoil
exactly what that is however we do like
obviously get very dressed up and things
take a very strange turn but a very
Cheryl blossom asked her a very blossomy
turn
feel free to tremble I typically like to
dress up but I don't really enjoy going
out okay so like two Halloweens ago we
went to a party together yeah that's
when I was a snake you were a snake and
I was magenta from Rocky Horror Picture
Show and then last year I didn't even
dress up and I stay at home and handed
out candy to the three kids who came to
our house literally three I can't
remember if I did I think I think me and
Michael just like literally sat no you
didn't go out yeah no we wouldn't had
wine and watched trick-or-treaters I'm
like that's kind of I mean and now that
I'm in my mid-20s I thought that's like
nice I still like dressing up though as
long as no balls dressing up a little
bit like I think I put like a witch head
on I just at least think about this but
we already got our Halloween fix this
year that's you know I'm senators begin
yeah yeah I agree 100% you got a little
two-part question for you guys
trick-or-treat which one you want first
Trick Trick who's the biggest prankster
on set and has there been a joke that
went a little too
we just got pranked by cager unison well
we did literally just get like five
seconds ago
Frankie pop I was a little far it was
like a little because I was like the
cameras were rolling and something that
really we were doing intimate scene and
he just pops up What did he say
he said oh it's about time I got a
little makeout scene yeah
very stressful what's funny though you
four are the architects of this outrage
now for the trait question which of your
Riverdale co-stars have done something
super sweet for you guys behind the
scenes I mean the other day you set my
room up with my little birthday present
that's true yeah she like I was like
you're a little bracelet yes yoshi i
gave me a little snake free splitter
necklace trooper necklace we just we
think for time yet she brought me coffee
this morning the sweetest and this is
why your best friends no you're right TT
okay let's talk about season four
we're gonna have more football games a
lot more vixens we're going back to that
season one vibe how are you feeling
about it I love to see the one I mean
only I didn't love about it was that the
nestled isn't than that it's like season
one one thing I thought I did love
season one like season one was still my
favorite as well but I'm really happy
that that's you know we're going back in
that direction relationship you know
where we all started where we came from
what made people love her for daylen
first place yeah I'm gonna forget the
day you saved me TT I got Roberto at
Comic Con to say this is the year that
Tony is getting her backstory I know
I doubt anything not yet but because he
said it I'm hoping that that's gonna
happen that I mean that's what I've been
waiting for I'm trying I have my story
like made up in my head you know mm-hmm
so I'm just like waiting to see it on
the paper that's you know reality of
what I think Tony's life is you know
here we go with the fake news again what
are you hoping to see more of this year
and what are you hoping to see a little
less of more of the relationships more
of like the Betty and Cheryl Team ups
the Veronica
team ups or Shoni like relationships up
a few like last year they have fighting
so much like I don't friend what kind of
almost no purpose I felt like and so I
want to get back to like what made Joni
fall in love in the first place you know
I think it'd be great to talk about
Heather coming back that's gonna happen
that'd be really cool and like I'd love
to see what's going on with my mom
excuse me but possibly for ELISA yep you
know what it is though it's like when
you're in it cuz we did all black hood
season to all gargoyle king season three
it's just like it's very what we're
doing it every day and then we also
watch it yeah I mean it's like we're
ready for whatever the new thing is and
the new thing is yeah it's good and it's
like it does it revolve around the
flash-forwards and I'm a a Jughead and
[Music]
it's good though it's good you're gonna
become BBH I don't even know what's
going on so yeah always love me honesty
but let's talk about Shoni what is
coming up with them in season four
because right now when we're seeing them
at the beginning of the season Cheryl's
got a lot of secrets that she's keeping
does that rock up their relationship a
little bit what the hell is going on
here
you never met Jason have you does it my
dear I don't know I mean if you were
keeping your brother's dead body in your
basement tapings meant taxidermied do
you think that your significant other
would be a little upset
I think we're creeped out I think you
would just be concerned yes yes what's
helped us notice I think yeah but I do
yeah but Tony there's some unconditional
love going on there yeah yeah mhm are we
also kind of seeing them step into like
a mom role almost because they're taking
care of baby twins I know right it's a
lot for Cheryl I mean like she's her
mental health is really at stake here
it's like how did it twins it there
could be some dead babies out of that so
why isn't Betty taking care of the twins
she's much more slinking on the street
Marilyn you and there are several that
yeah I have no idea why
it worries me leaving the twins alone
with her about we're at school but could
we get a fun Shoni date I mean I recycle
like a date
something's with nothing going wrong
going yeah okay sweet Joaquin is a
picture they like nothing going wrong
you know um okay well do another verb
okay she surprises school picks me up on
her a little motorcycle what a river
little picnic uh-huh and then the same
night I had planned to surprise you with
a new gang and you can call she's a
perfect segue to what is our status now
are we pretty poisons are we Southside
serpents what season four I don't know
the answer to that I mean I think Tony
always thinks she's a Southside serpents
gonna change hmm I think this is the you
know the pretty poison this is just her
like you know she just wanted to feel
like she was important like she was in
control of something yeah yeah girls a
vixen damn right yeah more musical
moments I'm sure between both of you I'm
sure I mean we always do this episode
the Halloween episode is my favorite run
for us I think I favorite one like
reading the actual script I always say
this I think episode four probably my
favorite script I've run on paper it's
really fun like Roberto has been talking
about a Halloween episode since
literally the pilots and so this is like
his dream come true to be doing it well
and it someone it sound like you guys
are there you were filming a little
steamy scene together potentially yes
mmm
you might have been maybe maybe not
maybe flawless as I've always known you
to be
you have a new addition to the Riverdale
cast curse Smith is coming on to play
principal honey but I've heard he's not
that sweet the character not where
either of you guys big Dawson's Creek
fans I never watched but honestly he's
so great when I we worked with him a
couple of times now and he was just
phenomenal like he's so he's like I
totally see why they picked him for the
role and it's fun to pick his brain
about yeah yeah he's told me just got
social media I know we helped them know
you have to like reach out to your
manager and get verified enough he's
like what do it really was like yes I
was like you know that your social
medias about to blow up and he goes
that's what the kids were saying your
name may be honey but I will always be
the queen bee you have no power over me
we are now in senior year of Riverdale
how does that make you guys feel and and
how much longer do you anticipate the
show going on for I feel old it makes me
feel old yes senior year yeah you're
here back senior year I think it could
go on forever a million years and a
movie that happened honestly a real
movie would be dough dough well it was
originally supposed to be a movie
Oh was mm-hmm Mike mm-hmm they should
end it with a final movie like a final
next time you know okay
lastly what is the one thing that you
are most excited for Riverdale fans to
see from you guys in season four what
excited to show them Shoni yeah so it's
kind of always my answer I go to answer
yes I know they're shutting fans right
hi I am too I think I was shipping you
guys before you even became a ship
you already people were really smart
people were let's move on that one
mm-hmm well because you guys just had
such a dynamic chemistry that friendship
just really wanted it people know it
happen
[Music]